what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here today John how
are you great how are you doing
wonderful guys today we are gonna watch
for the first time ever Barbarian This
is highly recommended by so many people
that's why we're doing it but before we
go into that we got a sponsor a sponsor
that we use so it always makes for the
most natural of Partnerships now if you
guys ever watch any of our horror
coverage I think it's pretty apparent
that horror is easily one of if not our
favorite genre in fact some of you may
know my passion is actually in
screenwriting and any script I've ever
actually completed is within the horror
genre so yeah Horrors my jam that's why
whenever the sponsor wants to work with
us it's always an instantaneous yes
especially because like I said earlier
we already use their service it's
shuttered come on you know it it had to
be shuttered it's Halloween time you get
like we love partnering with these guys
if you haven't heard of shutter which is
also on AMC plus let us be the first
people to tell you about it is a
streaming Channel dedicated entirely to
horror so if you're a die-hard horror
head it is perfect and just saying same
if you're one of those folks who waits
till October to get some horror movies
in to start up your Halloween spirit
it's perfect for you too you can also
use promo code home h-o-m as a mother e
for 31 off shutters annual subscription
they have an awesome selection of cult
classic films to iconic Hollywood
favorites in just about every sub genre
you could think of plus some really cool
playlists and original titles they've
got their own Creep Show Anthology
series they have a great documentary
called horror Noir which is all about
the history of black horror as well as
an anthology series and some of their
newest film titles include Chloe okuno's
Watcher as well as the new VHS film VHS
99 which just became their most watched
movie premiere ever they also have
original series airing right now
including the 101 scariest horror movie
moments of all time and queer for fear
which is all about the history of queer
horror they've even got a little
Christmas horror Anthology you might
just see a familiar face and just saying
maybe go check it out everything is
uncut and commercial free and the best
thing is you can save 31 on an annual
subscription when you hit up our special
link in the description box and use our
promo code home support the horror genre
and by supporting shutter it helps
support the channel so it's really just
a great cycle of return on on support
alright guys let's get to it
[Music]
Harry what is that
wow what a transmission
oh is this like an Airbnb situation oh
that would make sense yeah Modern Day
horror films an idea for spooky airplane
now stay with me
I'm running this place I I booked it on
Airbnb like a month ago I booked a home
away that's the other one foreign
look
it's unbelievable
what am I supposed to do make love
that's
pop some bottles why don't you come
inside and we'll call these idiots
uh what a clever way to capture someone
yep is that what's happening probably to
see Bill scars have been taking notes
would you mind pulling up your
reservation confirmation just so I can
see it
Smart in case I'm some kind of weirdos
broken in here to sleep yep it's
starting to give her attitude you got to
be understanding of the situation man
come on you got to know that you are the
threat here
I lady why would you go any further wait
till he does it I know I would have done
it outside
like get out oh my gosh
yeah it looks right to me listen I don't
know what the protocol is for this
me neither share room get to know each
other here's what I propose why don't
you just crash here
no I don't I don't think that's I don't
know you you take the bedroom and I'll
sleep out here on the couch and then
tomorrow we'll call these idiots get our
money back free stay for both of us
well I can't believe this this is such a
such a scary situation
there's no way I'm sleeping in the
bedroom while a young lady is sleeping
on the couch
blame it on my upbringing but it's not
up for discussion kind of have a thing
about clean sheets
nah man sleep on the couch you'd be
closer to the door yeah
[Music]
what if he's the owner huh
doesn't come across like a Brooklyn New
Yorker it's a fake ID
all these indie horror films have this
yellow lighting you creeper you creep
you know you might want some of this but
if I open it while you weren't here that
um that um I'm I'm I'm sorry I'm
rambling Jesus Christ like you're
getting at dude you're good I thought
you wouldn't want any if you didn't see
me open it so I waited
I'm good
[Laughter]
I looked around for some clean ones but
I couldn't find any I'll be fine yeah
I've slept on Mars you're evil because
you're evil evils
[Music]
in a movie
I thought it was great
prove it no one's seen that movie about
the makeshift Brass Band and there's
that scene with the kids on the rooftop
playing the coal train stuff yes
that's great I can't believe he saw that
oh no oh no because I'm actually one of
the founders of the lion Tamers we're
looking for new Spades so I'm here for
for a week basically just scouring this
side of town looking for our next little
nest what does that mean Nest hide
bodies
is it always the girls who get their
hearts ripped out in these things
girls can rip
trust me
she's gonna rip someone's heart out
some kind of foreshadowing back up
because now it gets hold on
a little aggressive with the thing but
that is how you
I was gonna
you are officially situated
yeah I think that about does it
laughs
stop looking at each other no leave
sleep there is a couch they need to be
putting gear years I'm so sorry oh don't
be don't be like I can sleep on anything
good night Tess
can I keep
no you're still creepy I don't give a
[ __ ] man
you mean your old family and all scars
are family which are freaks
to be a genre of Skarsgard horror
foreign
this is such a bad situation
no God does he murder in his sleep
Keith
oh yeah
[Music]
oh you not wake someone up when they're
having a nightmare like that nope
especially a guy
so I'm so sorry I'm just gonna I'm gonna
let you go to sleep did you open my door
no it's a matter yeah
is it the music making me wonder if this
could I don't know what's happening I
don't either I can't tell I can't tell I
think we're just as we're supposed to be
playing the creepy music
[Music]
wow you really can't tell any of that at
night
well it was really nice to meet you yeah
no I'm I'm excited I'm gonna call you
tomorrow okay this is gonna be great
huh she got the job it's a happy movie
yeah she kind of looks like Halle Berry
a little bit
It's oddly the one nice house on this
block yeah
what the [ __ ]
good key control oh
go away come out that house
my God
true nightmare she goes to the bathroom
a lot in this movie this movie really
does acknowledge the human biological
process
poster hey
oh my God so there's like someone down
here there must be maybe someone's
living in the walls
Google
of course
subtly creepy
damn it
[Music]
so
that's messed up yep oh my God
that is really creepy
nope
oh my God so like a whole ass tunnel
that's clearly a hidden room lady yeah
but it was just you know
oh
oh
she's an aspiring document here this is
the equipment I need even the lens they
capture with
yep grainy gross
do you have a key I I see here but I
can't open this all right
how do we know he's not responsible for
this we don't and I found this hidden
passageway in there was this room and it
was there was a bed and a camera and a
bucket so there's a bed and a bucket and
a camera paint a better picture test you
know blood stain on the walls do you see
it
yeah okay we'll come back up now
Keith
oh come on test test no Keith
this house was built on a slant
just let him die
okay so frustrated
don't go no it's the basement within a
basement
this is where you call it cop
come up here Keith no it's a trap
maybe go up and call the cops again
first
wow that's creepy
this is a
H what is going on oh
Keith if you are innocent you're a [ __ ]
does Airbnb regret having agreed to this
movie yeah
thank you
now why why did you come down in here
we have to come this way
oh my God what who was that
oh my God
Christ
oh
[Applause]
Keith was innocent the whole time I feel
so bad
I'm so sorry Keith
[Music]
I was so smart to cast him because you
knew that he was suspective because it's
him that was terrifying she's claimed
that you were sexually aggressive during
the filming of the pilot and she no
longer wants to move forward if you're
involved they're going to conduct an
investigation and then decide how to
proceed wow
I'm going to suggest that you find
alternate Wealth Management
wow
you're dropping me too
there's a lot of fascinating against
type casting here what no he's
definitely playing a 17 year old still
yep
the Plucky innocent 17 year old if I
could just have like a conversation with
her I could probably nip this whole
thing in the bud absolutely not under no
circumstances are you to contact her if
I just call her and just listen to me
this is such a weird movie I know
I think they're gonna arrest me I think
that is a very distinct possibility I
think that flying off to another state
is not a good look right now that is
true yeah yeah I'm an owner I'm here to
pick up a set of keys name
AJ
gilbride476 Barbary
there it is
what is this snake
the lady underground the property
manager
yeah she's the one who posts on Airbnb
home away or whatever she also manages
the Overlook Hotel
I was Tess just watching her get her his
head slammed
people go to the bathroom in this movie
frequently like real life well someone's
here there's a suitcase and clothes and
[ __ ] we haven't read
it well do we know when the last tenants
checked out do I have squatters
man-to-man like real talk like what the
[ __ ]
she just took some convincings off
that's it yikes ugh in the beginning she
was like oh whatever but like
then we started fooling around more and
then she was down like right [ __ ]
really loud I'm a persistent dude right
I'm like I had a Time
and she came around and that's it that's
what happened straight up
okay keep telling yourself that was one
I was like maybe you didn't yeah I know
maybe they want me to think
line between seducing an assault Hi
Megan this is AJ uh
I I just want to say that I'm really
really sorry if offended you or
because you know people people can have
different versions the same thing and oh
God
with chain air huh
good pick
how are you oh great he's gonna get
accused of murder too by the end of the
day I'm gonna get the whole rap sheet
tests
all right
what would a test password be
oh
great throw anyway look no you know how
he landed how many takes did that take
[Applause]
ah
great shot I have a gun
and I'm gonna come down there and just
open up on whoever I've seen about 30
seconds all right
or you can just come up here now and
I'll let you go
squatting my [ __ ] house
Jesus no squatters are a terrible
nightmare scenario though yeah it's very
real
and this
is smart enough to figure out how to
open that door
no it's an impressive squatter isn't it
the movie I want to name check but I'm
not going to spoil it for anybody
can underground rooms be listed in
square footage
when
this
is freaking cut can be noted separately
in the listing's total area
oh hell yeah
yeah [ __ ] do you even know what that
means
bring a few knives
[Music]
he does play this guy very real yes
like I know this personality
oh gross
10 by 12 that's 123 by numbers
the keeps on giving
oh [ __ ]
this is like I love this a whole new
definition of a dumb character
oh dear old new kind of dumb horror
movie character this is this is
beautifully done
what the [ __ ] is this hello
wow the way they use darkness in here
oh god what the [ __ ]
[Music]
that is scary yeah
who's there
wow these lenses
oh this feels like a video game yeah
keep counting the square footage yep no
stop peace
did you bring your phone too
getting closer
it's getting close
ah
oh no
jeez
what is happening we're in the past now
looks like it is this the origins what a
weird film
actually
oh nothing good coverage
[Laughter]
but it's not easy and there's so many
name brands to choose from but how do
you know which ones aren't voted
wow this movie is so well constructed
it's inspiring it is yeah I would love
to see the script for this
plastic sheets plastic sheets we have
some on seven
diapers some baby stuff
it's a bit by this way come on I'll take
you here
I
the tape yeah so it must be the dad or
that girl down there yeah
what crazy production design
sometimes you can feel the cameraman
yeah
like you really feel like you're one
with the camera in this yeah
like the the way they use perspective
and this is so engaged
are you in the market this guy's a
killer
Martindale Motors will make sure you
walk outside
of Wheels
[Music]
and Martial Motors is the motor city's
number one used car dealership
that's super creepy
foreign
you look like a Carlos
Richard break man
how many creepy people can you play
sorry to bother no bother we've got some
outages in the neighborhood and I'm just
checking to make sure everything's up to
par
I'm gonna use this bathroom
foreign
way for him to break back in we're
moving Frank yeah I hate to do it you
know but the wife thinks if we don't do
it now we may not be able to get out
this time next year because you know
neighborhood's going to hell Frank
it sure looks like it not even
questioning the Carlos name tag
not going anywhere
wow
what wild production
[Music]
no oh no no
oh okay
[Music]
oh my God
all she knows how to do is be a mom
this wants you to be baby
oh
foreign
what is she
look at those creatures from The Descent
[Music]
this movie is something else
[Music]
now would be the time to strike her
oh she's got like some type of unnatural
human strength yeah
come on Tess
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah I knew it no no no
sure drank from the bottle man
oh how the tables have turned Justin
Long
yep yep
great
damn clever script man yeah [ __ ] forgot
all about that [ __ ]
kick it open
should I close the door
[Applause]
[Music]
come on oh my God you got this you're so
close you were so close you're so close
you're so close no you've got to be
kidding me hopeless man no
or maybe he knows oh yeah maybe he was
actually trying to save her this whole
time
but I know she's in there
nerve-wracking and she ain't even the
worst thing that's in there what you
need to worry about you now I stay by
the water tower Escape come on wait wait
wait wait wait wait no no we can't leave
him we have to call the police I ain't
got no phone
she will kill him I need to help him and
how you gonna do that ever again
she comes out at night
if you want to get going then go
I'm back
and don't you be around here when it
gets dark
she's got to rip her heart out
what else is there
what's the something that's worse in
there like a feral underground baby
maybe Richard break is still alive Texas
Chainsaw Style
[Music]
how would the baby be worse
I don't know
I'm okay if Justin Long dies
no no
sure
go deeper
what choice do you have how far has she
gone
so much square footage
he is alive oh Christ do you have any ID
are you listening to what I'm saying
I've been held prisoner so you don't
have ID I don't have anything I am a
woman who has been held prisoner and has
escaped and I'm telling you that there
is a man in serious Danger
water
okay yeah
good
foreign
we're gonna get out of here okay
gonna get out I'm gonna get help
I'm gonna let everybody know what's
going on down here
you're saying all the wrong things what
do you want
and this is trash I don't know what you
want
to pull the string I've had enough of
you you're lucky we don't bring you
downtown to sleep this off in jail
sleep this off she's bleeding
where where are you going
please please don't go
my stuff
is that guy related to him maybe that
guy was behind the wheel when they drove
off oh
my God there's a lot
some of those labels
puker blind oh gas station
leftover no choice not a night
what's wrong with you yep
[Music]
oh
my God yeah
yeah
yes
[Applause]
use your windshield wipers yes
[Music]
damn she does have Richard breaks eyes
maybe it's him and a lady man this is a
crime
Patrol between these cars
oh please don't kill Tess I'm so so he's
gonna shoot her please for the love of
God yeah don't do one of those movies
don't do one of those no no no no no
horror movie no don't do it we've become
so far please
come on please don't neither the Living
Dead us now no don't that was just so
frustrating please don't
oh
[Music]
hello
crock of [ __ ] that is [ __ ] hey hey
can you okay okay
I'm so sorry come on we gotta get out of
here okay I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
oh please tell me she's still there
she's going she's gone she's gone
what are we looking at
I gotta be here somewhere oh
the water tower yeah yeah yeah
he used to bring women down there and
then he started making babies with him
and babies with the babies and you make
a copy of a cup oh and you end up with
something like that
wow which way to get her help huh you
all need to just sit right here and wait
can't I can't do that this is my fault
it don't matter whose fault it is it
does I heard somebody
oh but he's about to he's about to fast
up damn
change what I've done
I can just try and fix it
and that's what I'm gonna do you ain't
gonna do nobody no help if you go out
there and get yourself killed
he wasn't talking about you know he's
talking about something completely
rebirthing did you get news out here
how do you know she can't get in here
[ __ ] I've been living in this place more
than 15 years and she ain't never came
in this [ __ ] oh jeez so you give
her a reason
no no no no
that is why'd you run away it was a
strong copy of a copy of a copy
[Music]
barbed wire
you shove the gun
yeah
wait for me dude
remember about you did this
you're gone
just the definition of an idiot
there's nowhere to go
don't stay by the circus I can get away
we're gonna have to slow her down no
what baby
[Music]
what
you awful awful human being
uh
did you break his fall or her fault
that's what it looks like how would she
have possibly gotten ahead of her I was
like how would you grab and twist but
foreign
oh my God oh my God are you okay oh my
God shoot the woman in the head first I
have no time to think
panicked sure you did you started to
slip there's nothing I could do you get
it right okay you can be okay I got you
I'm saving you you're okay
thank God
do your worst lady oh buddy wow
whoa she just flips
no let her take care of you
[Music]
oh
what my baby
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh Bill Skarsgard produced it yeah
sweet well done Bravo it's a good movie
that was a ride there's nothing in the
credits right no it's not supposed to be
there's no point sticking around
who cares who cares about the hard work
all the different people who made this
puzzle yeah who gives a [ __ ]
yeah no that was uh that was brilliant
that was a brilliant movie that was so
well constructed so surprising
I I didn't know I read all I knew was I
or Justin long and Peter Skarsgard were
in this film and that it was a great fun
horror film
but uh Bill not your favorite Skarsgard
eater what did I say you said the
Peter's got his bills
kept feeling like it was an independent
horror film all right this is Fox film
we had like Disney he said just screwed
that Disney I remember uh invited us to
some screeners yeah we're just gonna go
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like a Fox
Searchlight so I don't know if they
maybe acquired it later if they threw
down some funding or whatever but yeah
it's like the upper side of Indy no it's
a fun movie and it's really well it
handles its reveal as well right up to
the you know the character with Justin
Long too yeah like you
because like to me it's like no test is
the start of this movie and test is the
[ __ ] like she was great like I could
have watched the whole movie it it has
an interesting game with the audience
because when it's switched to Justin
Long
it took me some time by like time in
like 10 minutes to adjust because I just
wasn't digging it as much as I like I
was enjoying it and I liked the weird
abrupt choice about it and how it was
connecting but I was really just fully
locked in for the movie of them like
Bill Skarsgard and and uh bill right
yeah and Bill's cars card and Georgina
Campbell yeah them being locked down
there and then dealing and uncovering it
you know I was on the board for the for
the first movie they were pitching us
you know yeah for those three movies in
here and they and what we did was we we
hopped around until they all sort of
watch how they're tethered and watch
other all comes together but I was on
board for that first movie
so I'm going to cut
to to this other thing and it has such a
different tone it took me a while
because Justin long is it like while a
great actor that Justin long he's a
great actor and uh I thought he nailed
this role I was like but it was really
emotionally busted in the test character
yeah absolutely and part of you is like
yeah I would totally have watched the
the real time Thriller of this but I
liked what they did I I was like no I
wouldn't have it by the end of it all I
wouldn't have it any other way yeah is
my point I'm getting to is like while it
was it took some time to get on board
for it
um hey yeah because I because I could
have sworn that test because I was sold
test was dead basically and I I didn't
see any reason she'd still be alive yeah
there's no reason that so the way they
handled their it does a good job at
reeling you in and making you question
what is going on and not knowing where
it's going but wanting to see it through
to the very end like you wanted you just
you gotta find out where this is going
you know like if I was by myself I
wouldn't be turning this off like this
was a very engrossing film
with uh such great
Panache to the way it was executed
totally it was so well constructed and
so well thought out it was one of those
movies that I imagined they kind of shot
for the edit because it's you get that
Vibe because the editing is so well
calculated the direction is so strong
with phenomenal performances uh
throughout Kate Bosworth is in this she
was a voice and Sarah Paxton like you
know there were some favors in here
absolutely I want Kurt bronhole or the
neighbor he's like a comedian the
director played uh a character he's a
writer too of it yeah get that
impression yeah yeah I know exactly how
cool
yeah it's not an insult like it's it's
just so well calculated and man what a
force to be reckoned with of a filmmaker
my God what else has he done
I'm so curious this is like one of those
instant I want to see everything a first
movie there's no second movie
he did Miss March a bunch of TV shows
The Whitest Kids you know movie damn
rest in peace Trevor Moore well there's
a dark comedy touch to this yeah
absolutely yeah absolutely a really
strong dark comedic touch to it but yeah
trying to let you say some things from
the meantime yeah no no dominate this
conversation no for sure this was this
was a very satisfying and gratifying
ride and and yeah it's one of those
things where it unfolds in a way where
it's constantly poking and prodding you
and it's constantly throwing these it
plays yeah on your own suspicions both
of the actors and the circumstances and
just the unfolding of like oh man secret
passage like it seems like it only gets
weirder and stranger but not in a way
where it feels like what is the weirdest
thing we can throw at you like there is
a logic and I like the way I like movies
like this that will throw you around and
disconcert you and then by the end
you're like okay clearly there is a
logic here and you know clearly you drew
out a linear map of this and then sort
of mixed it up to create the most
satisfying version of The Narrative
um but yeah it just creates its own
little world and I'm glad that it ends
the way it does it's so definitive
because in that moment where they're
like that's not the worst thing down
there I was like oh I can already
imagine how this might you know set up a
sequel in a world where this is
slaughtering the you know independent
horror box office but I like that they
didn't seem to pull any punches or or
you know hold any bars and yeah they
create this fascinatingly weird Venn
diagram of you have the immediate
physical Stakes of the situation but
then you also have this weird emotional
quality where becoming very aware of who
this guy Justin long is especially after
having all the suspicion surrounding
Bill uh Skarsgard that doesn't prove uh
you know merited as far as we know and
then yeah having this having that play
on your experience with it because with
Tess you are so much like no I want you
to survive I want you to endure and I
want you too ultimately escape and with
him it is like you could kill him you
could yeah yeah and then when they get
him both together I think that
solidifies a nice sort of Brilliance
because it's like
in a way it's a fascinating little
debate she's like you know without the
knowledge she's like well I have to go
back and save him and then you know you
have those moments where they are sort
of on an even plane and then you
graduate to where he has the upper hand
and ultimately makes the dastardly
decisions and so like there's a great I
feel like this combines The Best of Both
Worlds in terms of one of those like a24
Styles psychological you know uh
thematic horror movies but that also has
a monster element that is you know just
as visceral and icky as you know
something much lockier you know I was
reminded of a lot of different movies
in ways where it wasn't like oh here's
an homage to The Descent or parasite or
uh any number of other things but like
it seemed to borrow those kinds of story
components but use them in its own very
unique and Bleak way yeah well they're
set up for character wealth especially
with like with tests they set her up
really well as like with the kind of
career Pursuit that she has and she
would be someone who is extra observant
yeah who could pick up on things and
kind of figure stuff out so it made
sense to me that she would be able to
determine like okay she wants me to be
her baby and then her being kind of like
it's it's a it's it's a really cool
um you know final girl Ascension of
coming into her own strength because you
know when she Witnesses
Keith which Witnesses Keith really smart
to cast that was like a reverse psycho
kind of casting or reverse uh or reverse
shining yeah it's kind of like a reverse
Drew Barrymore scream like up here like
it's Bill Skarsgard It's gotta be he's
got to be yeah he's always evil I know
not to trust him he's an evil man yeah
you know trigger Pennywise come on
everybody's always a disturbed
individual you know like so you just
kind of assume he's gonna be bad and uh
yeah and the way he plays it and I think
him having a a producer
um attribute to this contribution to
this probably really clued him into
exactly how he had to do the performance
like no the audience has to be
suspicious of him they have to suspect
the best way to experience this without
a trailer I have no idea what the
trailer is so I have no way of telling
you of of like like I'm fascinated with
films like this how do you pitch this
how do you Market it I mean the obvious
pitch is you know what if you went to an
Airbnb in some like crazy [ __ ] you know
like what if there was something actual
malevolent living underneath the house
that you were at so it's a it's a solid
what-if scenario of you know I could see
that pitch but in terms of like the the
Mad cap surreal weirdness that this
movie goes down and and structurally
like I have no idea how you can bear
that to an audience so I I think this is
I think the best way to go into this is
as blind as possible but yeah when she
first sees Keith get murdered you know
she's Frozen in her tracks she's just
paralyzed at the sight of it you know
and as much as a lot of us would love to
imagine if we were in a scenario like
that we might fight back or stop it
um you know I could think of a couple of
people who would definitely be like no I
know them instinctually they go in
probably like that [ __ ] affects
something happened like I know a couple
of people like that is one in particular
but um but I think most of us would
probably be just so fear-stricken by
something of a site like first you're
dealing with such a horrific site you're
already in a state of fear based off the
environment you're in and and then
you're seeing something so such a crazy
um peculiar Oddity you know just to
destroy annihilating someone in front of
you like you would go into shock yeah
like a lot of us would like you just
wouldn't know what to do and I think
that so that her being so filled with
fear is kind of what saved her and then
by the end she fights back and then
there is that like um and they they
illustrate her well I'm trying to get as
like I think it's written really well
like it's so easy to look at the
directing and the cinematography which
is phenomenal yeah it's phenomenal but I
think it's also the kind of screenplay I
feel can be overlooked because it's a
really well done it's it's it I mean
it's the same director yeah it makes
sense
but yeah I think in terms of scripting
it so it makes sense by the direction of
what to do with your actors is so well
done because now I'm like oh yeah that
kind of girl who would get a fear struck
in a situation like that and then you
see her by the end when before she pulls
the trigger that there is this quality
where she can see like this this monster
is kind of like a Universal horror
monster absolutely 100 yeah you're not
this is not your fault the way you are
and why you are the way you are and I I
get it and I feel bad for you and I feel
sorry but you're also like I gotta
Murray
yeah yeah it's probably sympathetic
towards your existence though you might
not understand as well because I mean
you know you live feral underneath the
house and yeah I love that Touchstone
too because it does seem truly like it
does borrow monster movie Aesthetics and
she pulls Jane air out which is like a
Gothic
semi-romantic Horror Story in and of
itself and there is that it's like
there's so many great things mishmashing
here because like especially with you
know the woman or whatever she's called
and kind of reminded me of the woman
that movie where you know you have this
feral
woman but it's a reverse scenario where
she can't speak but she is the aggressor
here and even like it reminded me of
like a found footage movie like wreck
like there's so many things it takes but
I think it yeah it it uses all the
Thematic elements just as much as it
does the visual elements of those things
well I think it's a good character thing
because you know a lot of we're we're
like cliche people at like a a a low
quality theater shouting at the screen
sometimes in the First Act of this movie
yeah like what are you doing woman get
out of there okay go to the creeper come
on here come the [ __ ] get out of there
don't go in there don't go down four
stairs
the flashlight which keeps going further
in there what's going on
um you know you're just like shouting at
them uh but I wouldn't it's like while
there's some choices that feel very
horror movie of come on don't be stupid
like in real life whenever I'm in any
I've never been in any like truly
horrific scenario I haven't
but if anything presents itself as a
Potential Threat I take every like
strong caution possible you know like I
try to become very calculated as
possible very calm but intense it's like
I'm one of those people that when Panic
happens like that I become hyper focused
and like let me think of every scenario
use the flashlight record with my phone
I become like this weird machine so I
start thinking that but with Tess I
thought was cool was
I under I weirdly was buying into how
this was all progressing you know like
with her being in the house as much as
like it's going to be a threat the way
the conversations were done you're like
okay I just think it's a smart man even
with you know because a lot of times
music it's you can put a different track
a different type of musical composure on
something and you can have a different
response to any scene so they would play
like spooky scary music with situations
with Keith yeah but you had nothing to
fear about the guy so it's a clever
manipulation on the audience but and it
and it's not too much because you are in
her shoes going like I I would be
suspicious yeah but if you play the
right music you're watching a rom-com
yeah I can absolutely see the flip
version we're one of charming coincidink
and now we're just in for the weekend
and finding true love yeah who would
have thought that this situation would
presented some because when he is saying
there are smart things that are being
said
um there's a lot of like bodily fluid
stuff in here like bathroom the
pregnancy the birth the feedings
bodily fluid things yeah a lot of
acknowledgment of that which is which I
find it's
I can't tell if it's like a thematic
intent because then you go down
underground and it's like reverse Texas
Chainsaw Massacre words like we've been
living here since the you know 40s you
know no matter how rundown it gets just
peeing in bottles yeah we don't have the
advantage of the upstairs plumbing and
so I don't know maybe there's some kind
of hidden commentary about poverty in
there but but yeah it does seem like a
weirdly intent Motif throughout the
movie it's interesting to see a movie
that I really appreciated the flashback
with Richard break and how they include
they they told you the the origin like
you kind of you picked up on what I mean
I didn't think it was like baby within a
baby with a baby
but you got it was pretty it became
apparent like okay yeah it's got to be
at least his daughter in some way right
yeah um
even if it was a non-consensual way he's
gonna be his daughter and the the way
they handled that where you you see the
flashback and you I've seen so many
stories I've never been to uh Michigan
myself I've never been to Detroit myself
you know but in my in my cozy Los
Angeles perspective I everything I ever
see that is depicted in Detroit just
looks like it's just like the worst
place to visit right now and they're
always dealing with the worst things and
I see a lot of stories about
gentrification over there and run down
neighborhoods and stuff and it they
utilize the backdrop of Detroit very
well and different in a way that I
hadn't seen dumb before especially with
the way they handle the flashbacks of
look at this stream beautiful white
neighborhood and here they're going a
neighborhood's going to [ __ ] here we
better get out while we can we better
get out it's all going terrible is it oh
my God this looks great yeah looks like
dyllic and the way in the cinema who was
the cinematographer
um because yeah the way they handled the
darkness was so well done and how they
utilize it for transitions I was very
impressed with this movie it was very
impressive yeah and it made me think you
know because you do have it it allows
you I think the the benefit of having
those logical you know Rowdy in a horror
movie theater kind of responses like
especially at first when they're when
he's like have you seen this area and
we're like I mean you know outside it
didn't look that bad and then the next
day she goes out and you're like oh oh
yeah I get it you know I didn't see it
last night but today I do see why you
wouldn't feel at all comfortable in this
neighborhood and and yeah like the use
of light to even just mask that you know
at first because it plops you in in a
way where you're like oh nice little
house you know quiet neighborhood
Zach cooperstein nope never seen any
movie this guy's done interesting I
wonder what the lookbook on the pitch
deck look like for this film that's a
good like what were the films they
referenced for visual aesthetic because
yeah there's some
there's some interesting touches here
sometimes it really felt like a video
game oh those those like really wide
angle like POV arm shots or that that
that especially that yeah moment with
Justin Long well I think what they what
like I said at one point I think when it
felt like the camera was you were the
audience with the camera like sometimes
a lot of times you got to make the
audience unaware of the camera and that
actually worked with it's a it made it
more effective to feel like you are the
camera without doing the whole handheld
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know like that's
usually what they do to make it feel
more realistic okay yeah yeah and uh
while there's like handheld moments the
there's a lot of the way it was mounted
which was kind of like those subtle
David Fincher touches we saw that
wisecrack video forever ago where they
talked about how David Fincher was those
subtle moves he'll move with character
movements you wouldn't even notice it's
moving yeah until like someone points it
out to you yeah but it's so subtle that
it like reels you in and and I and I I
feel like that was sometimes happening
very you know apparently but other times
it was happening in ways I felt more
subtle well they they made yeah instead
of going like oh gritty handheld which
which they do at times and again lends
itself to some of the sort of like
almost found footagey elements in the
more intense moments but I think they
really made a great use of wide angle
lenses to convey that sense of you are
there as well as like really kind of
long zoom lenses that allow you to kind
of yeah focus in on the person that
you're you're seeing with a little bit
of that background blur but in a way
that still feels like you are voyeuring
in on them like it is you said
voyeuristic I think at one point early
on even in that like City Scene you know
where you feel the safest you still have
that quality of like I don't know
something's lurking something's watching
and I feel like I am in the room for it
too which is all the more uncomfortable
and it's it's uh impressive because it
is a stylish movie but where this style
yeah doesn't usurp the intent of the
style you know it's it's it's
substantial style yeah yeah yes which is
the thing you gotta really
try to aim for these days yeah and
especially with horror like horror is to
be like the way they do horror Horrors
this is a great example of why I love
watching horror films because stuff like
this is just the most exciting and it's
not like massive budget you know and I I
feel like the way they handled
um the AJ character was smart because
they let you in on like no he did do the
deed yeah did do the the awful thing
he's the snake and and then the way they
play with tropes is fun because you know
the second I was about to get really mad
at the movie yeah and they mess with you
they mess with you in the book I think
it's so intentional like they have fun
with the audience where you do where
like Tess is shot and I was like you
gotta be kidding me what a bunch of
[ __ ] yeah because it seems so
awesome
yeah it seems so obvious that it would
happen and and then uh but then they uh
they subverted that expectation
and then even with AJ they did that too
where you're like you're really gonna
have a Redemption story for this guy
yeah
I love that too because he again he's so
good at playing it that it's a nice
moment in isolation but yeah like I like
that they kept his his troop like when
it really comes down to it you watch him
bargain with himself and you watch who
that person's psyche is author the
entire situation oh he's a total
narcissist yeah totally and uh and and
then in the he and then you even see
yeah when when he does go to pick up
Tess that he's trying to sell in other
stories bargaining yeah yeah it's it's a
bunch of [ __ ] so I'm like no that's
that is the kind of person this movie
you know so I thought that was really
effective and the only predictable
moment the only predictable scare moment
because all the scare stuff really got
me but the only predictable one was when
she popped up behind the homeless guy
yeah it was the only time I was like oh
come on that's the most cliche like it's
pretty obvious she can't get in here
yeah look at the way you're framing your
shot yeah
it's the only predictable time
um I like that guy too that guy's great
and that's another great subversion yeah
of exploring the city of Detroit you
know there's something that felt like
very 70s horror about it uh 60s 70s
horror about it yeah it has well because
I think it does yeah really nicely to
blend that sensibility with the modern
style because so much of what you are
doing
with the characters is kind of watching
them in mundane moments that are just
unfolding you know just stuff is kind of
happening and then you stumble into uh
you know the The Perils and I think you
know it's what's the difference because
you know modernality we don't let
everything just you know kind of sit and
unfold quite as gradually as the 70s
movie does but I was sitting there
thinking during that that scene where
Justin long is like is Googling a floor
plan and square footage finances or
whatever and he's just kind of just
reading it off and just kind of going
over like Monday and stuff like I
wondered how much improv even there
might have been with some of the lines
because you are just sitting there for
and I think that like the bathroom thing
kind of lends itself to that too you're
just watching like regular people stuff
for so much of it and yet it's well
lived in by the actors and well
motivated by the situations so you don't
get like the deepest dive into who these
people are but they do feel alive and
they do Feel Again present in a way
that's then assisted by all the style
and you know cleansing and stuff yeah I
think everything all around was pretty
pretty awesome I thought this was like
an awesome film they like quickly became
one of my favorites slight Place Beyond
the Pines vibe to it with the way they
do the narrative all circling around the
history of this house uh it's like a
weird Creepypasta well I like that too
like it's it's it has just enough little
not quite Supernatural but there's
something about like man this is this
house just ever since you know Disney
started up his torture dungeon down
there it just seems like a Paul lives
over this house and no good can come of
this and through all this negligence of
you know the owners passing it down this
is all allowed to happen that's a
strength of evil Vibe and then yeah she
has this superhuman kind of wiriness
that I guess
Supernatural yeah yeah she's crushed by
a car
yeah it falls off a water tower it is I
guess crushed by the weight of at least
another person so yeah yeah she's very
it was like how would you I didn't even
think a gunshot would would enduring to
be honest yeah like I got to that point
but I love that would be the 80 sequel
starts off on the picks up right after
it just gets killed yeah
but yeah she killed her in the first
five minutes yeah
um yeah all right well
good parenting movie
guys what'd you think about Barbarian
leave your thoughts down below be sure
to subscribe click that Bell leave a
like and
um yeah we will uh catch you all soon
but we'll also shout out some patrons
not gonna make a John boyega joke sharks
in the water with Zachary Barker are you
Clive Barker you know Halloween season
might have been better whatever yeah you
get it Irfan chowder hungry talking wall
Clocky Ian's I'm in song High Glover
Jacob nepotism never mind bro fan cops
Alan John Carpenters the Ling Logan
Scorsese
[Music]
Kira from Death Note hahaha ericcon 69
dude
there's a snake in my boot
NYX CK Spanish John Longoria Gail
weathers Ferguson
muhammaduke
Sharon won our Texas Ranger Cliff
commonly used Latino name
Charlie Alex Day Master tits
John the boat Andy
Ray Liotta backstabber you're crazy
[Music]
[Laughter]
macro tungsten Lauren C biscuit simply a
stoner your highs stop it Joanna Saint
Mod Rogue scroll so Jewish 94 Jason
manzukis Rosie Beatty Kirk the cars
I see what you did there Colleen Phillip
Jesus Smith Jen Jesus Smith the Honda vs
blocker
laughs
fight round one you gotta mix it up guys
finish finish him fine just figure out
which name was yours it's on screen you
can read
well we love you all happy to shout you
all out yeah thanks for being here
thanks for joining us every month all
month hopefully this went over all right
leave your feedback
thank you